hagamos más problemas que involucren las
leyes de Newton este problema se
seleccionó de la página de la
Universidad de Oregon su sitio es
zbu uor r e g
a.edu para darles el crédito
correspondiente a este problema el
problema dice que tengo un tren vamos a
dibujar Aquí más o menos un tren Este es
el el suelo
este es
más o
menos el tren lo mejor que lo puedo
dibujar al menos una parte del tren aquí
está el humo que
sale Y esta este tren tiene una
masa igual a
6.84 * 10 a la
kilogramos y se mueve a una
velocidad de
80 km por
hora Esta es su velocidad inicial
velocidad
inicial y bueno en este problema nos
dicen que tiene unos frenos que producen
una fuerza neta hacia
atrás de
1.93 Vamos a ponerle fuerza de los
frenos y se Iguala
1.93 por
10 a la
newt y estos frenos se van a aplicar
durante 25 segundos y la pregunta es
Cuál será la nueva velocidad del tren
después que se aplicaron los frenos
bueno tenemos nuestros datos nuestra
masa del tren la velocidad inicial de 80
km/h eh la fuerza de los frenos Vamos a
ponerle subíndice B
1.93 * 10 a la 6
New
6 y el tiempo van a ser 25
segundos
Bueno vamos a calcular qué tan rápido
está desacelerando el tren o qué razón
de desaceleración crea esta fuerza hacia
atrás Bueno vamos a regresar a nuestros
conceptos
básicos nuestra fórmula que quizás la
que es tenemos más fácil de memorizar
fuerza es igual a masa por
aceleración en este caso conocemos la
fuerza hacia atrás la fuerza de de los
frenos que es de
1.93 * 10 a la
6 Esto va a ser igual a la masa que es
6.84 * 10 a la 6 kg por la
aceleración la aceleración hacia atrás
es lo que queremos encontrar y Esto va a
estar dado en metr sobre segundo al
cuadrado solo quiero asegurarme de tener
bien mis unidades ya que ojo la masa fue
dada en
kilogramos eh tenemos que eh hacer la
transformación o bueno no tengo mis
unidades bien porque tengo bien mis
kilogramos este y estamos trabajando en
newtons Entonces vamos a hacer el
cálculo para despejar la aceleración va
a ser
Ah okay antes de hacer el cálculo
tenemos que la aceleración va a ser
igual a
1.93 * 10 a la 6 entre si pasamos esto
de este otro lado de la ecuación Entre
6.84 * 10 a la 6 Este término como se
divide entre el mismo Pues lo podemos
omitir Ahora sí usamos la calculadora y
es
1.93
entre
6.84 y nos queda a
0.282
0.282 Met sobre segundo
cuadrado Bueno qué tan rápido va a ir
este tren después de 25 segundos Cuál va
a ser el cambio en velocidad bueno
recordemos que el cambio en
velocidad lo vamos a tener dado por esta
fórmula cambio en velocidad es igual a
la aceleración por el
tiempo y si la acelera Bueno si la
velocidad es un valor positivo porque
bueno Esta es la velocidad que estoy
llevando pero mi aceleración va a ser
negativa porque se va a aplicar hacia el
lado opuesto hacia el lado contrario de
la dirección de la velocidad Entonces
sustituyo estos valores mi aceleración
que es lo que acabo de calcular y es en
sentido negativo le pongo
menos
pun2
82 Met sobre segundo
cuadrado por 25
segundos y usamos la calculadora para
hacer esta cuenta vamos a multiplicar
por 25 segundos y nos queda
7.05 este segundos Cancela Este Entonces
me queda
a
7.05
7.05 m sobre segundo Esta es la
diferencia en
velocidad y es negativa porque va hacia
el sentido
contrario okay Entonces tenemos que la
velocidad inicial del ten eran de 80 km
porh pero en cambio noten que la
velocidad que acabamos de calcular está
en metros por segundo Así que vamos a
tener vamos a tener que convertir
unidades vamos a cambiar eh en metros
por segundo estos kilómetros por h bueno
Cuántos metros hay en 1 kilómet bueno
tenemos que hay 1000 m en 1 km
Y tenemos este valor vamos a
convertirlo Okay a kilómetros por h
entonces haciendo nuestras conversión de
unidades tengo menos pun
7.05 entre 1000 para encontrar los
metros y eh
cuántas cuántos segundos en una hora
Bueno hay 3600 segundos en una hora Así
que esto lo voy a multiplicar por
3600 si esto les causa algún conflicto o
los confunde es este Bueno me estoy
saltando algunos pasos aquí pueden
regresar a los vdeos de conversión de
unidades para que esto les quede un poco
más claro bueno quitamos estos ceros se
cancelan con
estos y hacemos la
multiplicación
7.05 *
Entre
10 y me quedan
25.3 vamos a dejarlo o sea vamos a
aproximar Es aproximadamente igual a
25 km por
h bueno ahora sí si
con una velocidad
inicial de 80 km 80 km por hora Ah y
este no se nos olvide que es menos y
tenemos que nuestra cambio de velocidad
nuestra Delta B es igual a
-25
km por hora bueno Cuál va a ser mi nueva
velocidad bueno no recordamos que este
cambio en
velocidad va a ser igual a la
velocidad final menos la velocidad
inicial Entonces vamos a tener 80 men
25 igual
a
55 km por h nuestra velocidad inicial
menos nuestra velocidad bueno nuestra
diferencia en velocidad que es
y nos queda este
resultado como velocidad
final Okay y bueno la segunda parte de
este problema nos dice o nos pregunta
qué tan lejos ha viajado este tren
Durante este tiempo en lo que cambió de
ir a 80 km porh hasta llegar a los 55 km
porh una vez de haber frenado durante 25
segundos Bueno entonces necesitamos
encontrar la velocidad promedio
eh Y después La necesitamos multiplicar
por el tiempo nuestra velocidad
promedio vamos a
recordar la velocidad promedio es el
promedio entre la velocidad final más la
velocidad inicial entre dos Este es el
promedio eh sustituimos los valores
nuestra velocidad final es de
55 +
80 recordamos que tenemos las mismas
unidades de kilómetros por h en ambos
datos Así que podemos hacer el cálculo
sin problema y esto nos da un resultado
de
67.5
km por hora Esta es la velocidad
promedio la distancia que
recorrió La distancia es igual igual a
la velocidad promedio por el tiempo y
Recuerden que el tiempo nos lo dieron en
segundos sin embargo fíjense que nuestra
velocidad está en kilómetros por h así
que tenemos que hacer un cambio de
unidades cambiar la velocidad promedio a
metros por
segundo entonces de la misma manera que
hicimos la conversión de unidades aquí
lo voy a poner en otro color para que
para confundirlos un poco más Quizás
eh Para
convertir nuestra eh velocidad
promedio es
67.5 bueno Cuántos eh metros hay en 1
kmet hay 1000 ent son
67.5 por 1000 y aprovechamos cuántas
segundos hay en una hora hay
3600 entonces hacemos esta
operación de
67.5
por
1000 entre
3600 y nos da
18.75
18.75 ahora van si son metros por
segundo y ahora sí esto lo sustituyo en
la fórmula de manera que la distancia
recorrida es la velocidad promedio en
metros por segundo
18.75 Met por segundo lo multiplicamos
por el tiempo que fueron 25
segundos multiplicamos los valores
18.75 por
468.75
468.75 que bueno tenemos estos segundos
que cancelan con estos y son
468.75 Met la distancia que recorrió el
tren de ir cuando frenó de 80 km por h a
55 km porh en 25 segundos y este es el
resultado de la segunda parte de nuestro
problema vamos en el siguiente
video